No, that pitcher is good.
You're such easy prey.
Can't wait for tonight's game.
Oh, sorry.
This valve doesn't close very easily.
Be more careful.
I have to go back to the main prison
to change.
Hey, why did you hit me?
I said I'm sorry.
It's not like I got you wet on purpose.
Oh, did I hit you just now?
The hell is wrong with you?
I didn't smack you that hard.
You want some?
You didn't need to punch me hard, bastard.
-You jerk!
-Asshole!
Why you little…
All right, that's enough.
I said enough.
I said stop.
I'll apologize. I'm sorry.
I'll lend you my uniform
if you don't have a spare.
That settles it, right? Let's be done.
What got into you? Calm down.
Are you in a bad mood today?
We're friends… right?